today's episode is brought to you by
curiositystream an incredible and
Incredibly affordable place to watch
thousands of non-fiction movies and
shows more about them in just a bit
in 1969 Apollo 11 made history after
fighting the pull of Earth's gravity
powered by a Saturn V rocket with enough
chemical energy to rival a small atomic
bomb facing challenges like the Van
Allen radiation belts and the vacuum of
space Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
ultimately 10 others touched down on the
surface of the Moon and walked its Dusty
desolate surface so would you believe us
if we told you that this would never
have happened if it wasn't for a German
scientist childhood fascination with
science fiction and space travel this is
the story of a controversial German
scientist turned NASA director and how
his revolutionary rocket technology led
us to yearn for the stars the brilliant
and charismatic engineer who refused to
ever be acknowledged as a scientist and
the originator of the Saturn V rocket
Verna von Braun
foreign
[Music]
ER Magnus Maximilian Von Braun was born
on March 23 1912 in the town of wersitz
in Eastern Germany to an affluent
aristocratic family berner's father was
Magnus Freer Von Braun among other
things Magnus was a politician a
chemical engineer and a rocket scientist
his mother was Emmy Von Christophe a
musician and something of an amateur
astronomer for his confirmation in the
Lutheran Church Verna didn't get a watch
or even his first pair of long pants as
a famous quote from the man himself
attests instead his mother got him a
telescope thinking it would be the best
gift for the young man it's been
suggested that this was the inciting
incident that cemented Von Braun's love
of astronomy to help him further develop
his appetite for amateur astronomy his
mother also gifted him books by science
fiction writer H.G Wells and Jules Verne
he fell in love with the stories and was
particularly fascinated with the idea of
putting men in space Verner was not
alone in his love of space while his
brother sigismund Von Braun would become
a diplomat or an attache in the German
Foreign Service his other brother Magnus
would follow in their Father's Footsteps
to earn a degree in advanced chemistry
he like Werner would work on rockets at
the age of 12 earner showed off his
obsession with rockets by building a
skyrocket-powered wagon and sending it
screaming down an open Street an act
that attracted the attention of the
local police some sources seemed to be
in Conflict as to when the Von Braun
family moved to Berlin some like Bob
Ward's author of Dr space the life of
Werner Von Braun suggests that the
family moved to Brandenburg Berlin in
1915 While others suggest it was 1920.
whatever the case it was in 1920 when
Werner attended the French gymnasium
something of a high school equivalent
incredibly Varna excelled in all areas
pertaining to languages but flunked math
and physics and was sent off to boarding
school as a result burner attended the
Hermann leet school at edtersburg Castle
in thuringia Germany a boarding school
that emphasized practical trades that
were lauded for their Advanced teaching
methods at the age of 13 he read Rockets
into planetary science by space Pioneer
Herbert Noble the book capturing his
imagination but Von Braun struggled with
complex mathematical formulas and this
led him to swear to himself that he
would Master mathematics and physics
amazingly before he graduated he was
teaching and tutoring struggling
students in the same areas that he'd
struggled with and failed just years
earlier
in 1930 Berner Von Braun attended the
charlatanburg Institute of Technology in
Berlin and joined the German rocket
society which was founded in part by
erbeth Von Braun's Idol it was verna's
goal while studying to become hermanoba
thunderstudy Von Braun's goyles would
soon be realized and he would become
oba's assistant and together they would
build a small rocket engine in 1932 at
the age of 20 Verner received his degree
in mechanical engineering however the
rocket society that Von Braun and oberth
belonged to Iran into financial troubles
in the fall of that same year obath
would return to his home in Romania but
Verner would continue his research in an
abandoned field outside of Berlin using
deserted buildings as living quarters
and Laboratories but it wasn't until Von
Braun attended the Institute of
Technology in Zurich Switzerland that he
began to dive into the psychological
effects of space flight he conducted
strange experiments with mice in a
centrifuge which convinced him that
humans could indeed whether the
incredible force is required to break
Earth's gravity after this he returned
to charlottenburg and to his work with
the German rocket Society while Avon
Braun and his colleagues worked on their
Rockets Adolf Hitler and the Nazi party
were busy seizing power and taking over
the political structure in Germany the
Treaty of Versailles prevented the
German Army from having any weapon with
a barrel but the Nazi party saw a
loophole the treaty did not forbid the
use of Ordnance weapons and that became
the focus of military development the
German Army was impressed with Von
Braun's work and invited him to continue
with his research at their facility in
kumasdorf Von Braun officially joined
the German Army Ordnance rocket program
on October the 1st 1932 and two years
later he received his Doctorate in
physics from the University of Berlin
his work on the A4 rocket better known
later as the V2 was an especially
ambitious undertaking as it was to be
13.7 meters long and deliver a metric
ton Warhead to a Target 257 kilometers
away from its firing location the motor
inside the rocket was more powerful than
the largest liquid-fueled Rocket Motors
available at the time delivering an
impressive 22.6 metric tonne upward
thrust for 60 seconds blowing the
competition out of the water the
competition was was only able to reach
1.6 metric tons of upward Force despite
Hitler giving rocket development the
highest priority in envisioning them
ruins an instrumental thing in his quest
take over Europe Von Braun's team
encountered numerous setbacks in
perfecting the V2 the first launch did
not occur until October 3rd 1942.
failures continued to plague Von Braun's
team and the V2 was not operational
until 1944. by the end of the war in
1945 almost 6 000 Rockets were produced
and stored in an underground protection
site called metalwork even though
thousands of the missiles were launched
at London they were anything but
significant to the German war effort now
look you're a viewer of this Channel and
are they all sort of person who loves to
learn new things me too it's one of the
reasons that we do this challenge hey
look if you want to take that learning
further then you should definitely check
out the sponsor of today's video and
that's curiosity stream curiosity stream
is a streaming service that isn't filled
with low quality junk and reality TV
shows it's a collection of some of the
best documentary educational content
from around the world it's available on
whatever device you have from Roku to
Apple TV to Chromecast plus you can
access it worldwide with no Geo
restrictions now one of the neat things
about curiosity is that in addition to
their huge library of existing content
they're always adding cool new
documentaries I went and had a look and
see what was released recently and I yes
added a bunch of stuff to my to watch Q
so look you're enjoying a biography on a
Channel all about them well if you'd
like to get a more in-depth look at
people's lives that go beyond the 20 to
30 minute profiles we do here there are
some great shows on curiosity that
you'll love American icons looks at some
of the most notable people from American
history FDR Babe Ruth Lincoln and menu
anymore or hop over the pond for an hour
long documentary on Willian the
Conqueror and these are just a few of
the examples when we scratch the surface
so go to curiositystream.com biographics
you got unlimited access the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series for
you guys just use the promo code
biographics and you'll save 25 which
comes out to only 14.99 a year here
which is 1.25 a month which is an
extremely good deal and now back to
today's episode
[Music]
Hitler envisioned Von bronze rockers as
a weapon that he could use to force
Europe to bend their knees to him
throughout Von Braun's life he
maintained that he had zero interest in
developing his Rockets as weapons and
had always had his sights on putting men
in space but historians aren't so
certain this a modern interpretation
paints him as an opportunistic and
single-minded engineer who wasn't nearly
as disgusted by the idea of developing
weapons as he would have liked us all to
believe the chief reason for this new
line of thinking on bond Braun's
motivations is his work with the United
States military before NASA's Foundation
according to Von Braun he would have
used any facility given to him to
conduct his research and the military
were the only ones capable of providing
what was needed many academics agree on
this point but also highlight the fact
that Von Braun's associations have never
been adequately investigated any person
finding themselves in a nationalistic
regime might want to appear as useful as
possible but how far was Von Braun
really willing to go the German air
force luftwaffe offered Von Braun and
his associates five million marks to
engineer a rocket-powered plane at the
time 1934-1936 this would have been
worth somewhere in the ballpark of 1.2
million dollars in 2022 it'd be more
like 19 million dollars however the Army
ultimately won out against the German
air force funding was not an issue for
Von Braun and his associates from that
point onward this would not be the end
of werner's involvement o is the German
air force as he would become a luftwaffe
Cadet in 1936 and he were trained to be
a pilot in 1937 the German military
moved Von Braun and his illustrious
colleagues to pin NE munde off the
Baltic Coast on the island of uston the
engineering team at this top secret
location spent the majority of their
time focused on the weaponization of Von
bronze rockets in fact Werner and his
fellow Engineers were not allowed to
discuss the potential for peaceful
applications of this technology his work
resulted in the creation of the V2 a 14
meter tall rocket that sported a range
of around 321 kilometers this was the
world's first ballistic missile and the
German Army would set their crosshairs
on high-value Military targets like
Paris and London the trouble with this
is that the guidance system of the V2 is
rudimentary at best even though 7000
people the majority of which were
civilians did perish as a result of the
v2's use it was still not reliable
enough to contribute to Germany's war
effort on the whole despite penamunde's
ban on the discussion of peaceful
applications of this rocket technology
would go around that Von Braun was
making offhand comment alluding to his
real goal of using the Rockets of space
travel in 1944 Von Braun's comments saw
him imprisoned by the German SS without
Von Braun at the head of the Nazi rocket
development program it all but stagnated
and stalled Hitler's timeline for the
war however imprisoning their lead
rocket developer was seen as a poor
political move and Von Braun was
released in May of that year by Albert
Speer spear thought Von Braun could
still be of use and used his position as
Nazi official to get the process moving
on his release as the war came to a
close orders at panamunda or conflicted
of the ten orders given half-waunted Von
Braun and his associates to beat hold up
in the compound and fight to the death
against any encroaching Allied Forces
while the others suggested that Von
Braun and his team should hide somewhere
along with all of the research Von Braun
didn't like either of these
possibilities his colleagues were not
soldiers they weren't even armed and he
feared that the orders were a trap that
would end with them and his men being
held as hostages Von Braun suspected
that his chances would be better with
the enemies of his country but he had
his men vote on the course of action
fearing that they'd be tortured by the
Russians and worrying that the British
would be of no help to them the vote
resulted in Werner and his colleagues
deciding to flee and surrender to U.S
troops Von Braun also suspected that the
Americans would take Keen interest in
his research for the German military
what followed would be a lengthy
cross-country Expedition the team used
color-coded boxes to organize their
Convoy we're not talking about a small
band of Engineers making a short Trek
either but thousands of workers and
support Personnel in a fleet of
automobiles including cars trucks and
trains it would have been impossible to
pull off an operation of this magnitude
without attracting unwanted attention
from the German Army but thanks to
verna's high rank within the Nazi regime
he was able to deceive the Third Reich
and utilize official stationary to give
his his team and himself counted orders
to move all of these people to safety
with the help of these fake orders they
managed to surrender to American forces
on May 2nd 1945. after the war Von Braun
was brought over to the U.S as part of
Operation Paperclip Von Braun's Hope Was
That America would be the nation most
likely to use his research for space
exploration while being interrogated by
Allied Intelligence Officers Von Braun
presented them with a report in which he
forecasted trips to the Moon as well as
orbiting satellites and space stations
the United States recognized the
potential for those ideas and the US
Army transferred him and 112 of his
scientists and Engineers along with
technical rocket data and 100 V2 Rockets
to Fort Bliss in Texas using seized V2
Rockets Von Braun and his team conducted
high altitude tests sparking at the
start of work on what would become the
Hermes 2 rocket during this time Von
Braun was kept under heavy surveillance
due to fear of him being captured by
Russian or Chinese agents
[Music]
in 1947 at the age of 35 Verna Von Braun
received permission from the U.S
government to return to Germany and
marry a woman he knew only through
correspondence and had only met briefly
at penamundo he boarded a boat in New
York and sale time intending to bring
his parents back as ol as is betrothed
Maria von kistorp had yet to turn 19 and
according to some sources was Von
Braun's first cousin Von Braun's parents
delivered the marriage proposal and she
was accepted the two were married at a
Lutheran Church in lanshood Bavaria
under the constant surveillance and
guard of American MPS the couple weren't
able to have a honeymoon and or kept
separated on the ship back to the U.S
because ships at the time only allowed
women to have cabins whereas the men
slept in bunks with other GIS with his
parents in tow the Von bronze returned
to El Paso Texas by train at the end of
March 1947. o.a would continue to work
for the U.S army for the next three
years in 1948 Von Braun wrote about his
passion for space travel with his
parents and Maria in his spare time he
also wrote the Mars project a technical
breakdown of the challenges Humanity
would encounter while settling the red
planet it took until 1942 and 1953
respectively for German and English
Publishers to agree to print the book
[Music]
continuing work on the Hermes 2 rocket
for the U.S army came with plenty of
challenges and after three years of work
on the project it was canceled due to
its impracticality Von Braun always
outspokenly critical of the U.S
government's failure to give rocketry a
higher priority if the U.S had listened
to him perhaps it would have been them
instead of the Russians launching the
first satellite into orbit the greatest
challenge of the project was developing
a guidance system that could achieve a
much higher Target accuracy to say that
the Hermes 2's first launch was a
failure would be an understatement the
Hermes 2 was heavily reliant on the V2
in its first stage it was nicknamed the
Comet or the ram due to its Ramjet
design however Von Braun's team were not
experienced with developing ramjets the
v2's flaws included its guidance system
tail and Wing design when launched on
May 29 1947 from White Sands Proving
Ground the craft ended up Greening South
towards El Paso Texas instead of North
this caused the vehicle to land in
Mexico inciting an international
incident and forming a crater 50 feet
wide and 24 feet deep the U.S army
extended its most greatest apologies to
The Mexican government and it would
later be revealed that the guidance
system that Hermes II had relied on had
been wired backwards in April of 1950
Von Braun and his team were moved to
Alabama the Korean war broke out in June
and funding for a new project the
Redstone guided missile was increased
there was a renewed interest in
producing long-range Rockets despite the
low accuracy of the V2s of the past Von
Braun now led the guided missile
Development Division of the Ordnance
missile Laboratories in 1954 he had as
many as 950 people under him and four
years later almost four thousand from
bronze tenacity in managing large teams
of people proved quite useful to the U.S
army here and by 1958 the team would
launch its first satellite into orbit
just months after the Russian Sputnik
[Music]
Berlin was a household name in the
mid-1950s thanks to a series of articles
by Cornelius Ryan Collier's magazine and
several television shows on Walt
Disney's popular Disneyland TV series
The Articles and shows allowed Von Braun
to share his passion for the topic of
space travel and ignited America's
imagination for what could be possible
in the future Von Braun would serve as
technical advisor on free space-related
programs for Disney like Walt Disney Von
Braun saw the potential of Television to
influence the opinions of viewers in the
United States and with the help of Walt
Disney's Artistry he developed programs
which showed how human beings might
conquer space with their intelligence
and incredible technology Von Braun also
had a key role in shaping the
Tomorrowland theme park after the Airing
of his Disney man in space specials Von
Braun and more than 100 of his fellow
scientists became naturalized citizens
of the United States the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration was
created in 1958 and just two years later
Von Braun would end his career working
for the U.S army and be appointed as the
head of the George C Marshall space
flight agency a nazarone facility Von
Braun would end up leading the team
which would go on to develop the Saturn
V rocket in 1967 the Saturn V would
finally make its debut just before
Christmas of 1968 powered by the Saturn
Vibe rocket Apollo 8 would make its
history as being the first crude
spacecraft to leave low earth orbit
travel too and or with the moon these
crew members were the first to see the
Earth rise of the lunar Horizon as
Apollo 8 completed its single orbit of
the moon through 1969 to 1972 Von
Braun's team would go on to put six
teams of astronauts on the moon in 1970
Von Braun moved to Washington DC and was
made Deputy associate administrator of
NASA two years later being displeased
with the job and the budget cuts he
would resign to become the president for
engineering and developments with
Fairchild industries of Germantown
Maryland that same year humans landed on
the moon throughout the 1970s Von Braun
continued to promote space flight in
various capacities and founded the
National Space Institute 975 serving as
its first president he went so far as to
testify before Congress to make the case
for the further development of the Space
Program
foreign
Von Braun was presented with the first
Robert H Goddard Memorial trophy in 1958
and went on to win numerous other Awards
in 1959 Von Braun received the
distinguished Federal civilian service
award and in 1977 he was awarded the
national medal of science Von Braun was
diagnosed with kidney cancer in 1973 in
underwent surgery to have the kidney
removed once removed he resumed his work
but his declining Health would force him
to retire from the Fairchild Institute
by 1976. on June the 16th of 1977 Verna
Von Braun died of cancer at a hospital
in Alexandria Virginia he was 65 years
old and was survived by three children
in his wife Maria despite his effective
manipulation of television as a means of
covering up or erasing his history of
the Nazis and despite American leaders
and administrators covering up or
ignoring that history entirely not
everyone forgot and as the years have
progressed Von Braun's Nazi past has
become a hot topic for debate in this
way Verna Von Braun's Legacy will always
be highly polarizing on one hand some
view him as a Nazi war criminal an
opportunistic and charismatic villain on
the other hand there are those who argue
that if it weren't for Von Braun's
Research into space flight if it weren't
for his childhood love of Science and
fiction then we might never have been
able to obtain the incredible images and
data we have today of the surrounding
worlds in our solar system Von Braun
would often somewhat ironically invoke
Columbus Charles Lindbergh and the
Wright brothers when describing his
Ambitions stating that his goals were
always geared towards space flight
toward putting men on the moon creating
a moon base and Landing men on Mars he
famously stated that his B2 rockets were
perfect they simply landed on the wrong
planet we wouldn't have treated your
Atomic scientists as war criminals he
once said and I didn't expect to be
treated as one and perhaps both are true
perhaps human beings are not so simple
to put in a box perhaps we can be all
things brilliant generous and kind while
still being a bloodthirsty monster it's
an arguable that Von Braun exploited the
horrifying Nazi regime's facilities and
political power to achieve his goals but
it's also true that he was one of the
most influential rocket engineers of the
early 20th century
[Music]